The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
Today, we will
consider solutions
to systems of an infinite
number of degrees of freedom.
What we'll consider is when
you have identical oscillators,
which are coupled
only to the neighbors,
and there is an
infinite number of them.
So each one is an infinitely
small oscillator, as I say,
coupled to each neighbor.
The simplest example is
that of a taut string.
Each piece of that string
is a harmonic oscillator.
It oscillates transversely.
And each piece is identical
to every other piece.
And it's coupled
to its neighbors.
So let's consider the
following problem.
The problem we are going to
talk about-- the solution
of the following problem.
Suppose you have a string.
For practical purposes,
an infinite string.
It has a mass per unit length
of new mu, a constant tension T,
and at one end it's
connected to a massless ring.
This is an idealized situation.
You could imagine, suppose
that ring was on your finger.
You held the string taut
and you moved your finger
in some ways, which
caused a distortion, which
propagated down this string.
You got a progressive pulse
going down this string.
So this is an idealized
diagram of that situation.
I've indicated the finger
holding the string by,
you could imagine,
a massless ring
sliding on a frictionless
rod, for example.
And somehow or other, a force
is applied to this ring.
But you can think of
the actual problem
where you're holding the
ring with your finger
and moving this up and down.
Now, somehow or other,
you're moving this ring such
that as a result of your motion,
there is a progressive pulse.
And the idealized
pulse we'll consider
is a triangular shape
like this, where
this height is H and
the length from here
and here is L. It is idealized.
In reality, you can't have
sharp corners like that.
You can imagine there
is a very tiny curvature
at those locations.
Now, what we are told is
that at some instant t given
by 4L over-- and this is the
phase velocity of propagation
down the pulse over
square root of t over mu.
At this instant of time,
you look at the string
and you see that this is
the shape of that pulse.
And as a function of time,
that propagates to the right.
OK?
The question is,
what is the motion
of this ring as a
function of time?
That's one.
Two, what is the power that the
force which drives this string
delivers to the string?
So what's the power
as a function of time?
All right, next.
What is at any instant of
time the potential energy
stored in this pulse?
Four, what is the kinetic
energy stored in this pulse
as it's propagating?
And finally the question,
are your results
to the power that's delivered,
the potential energy
stored in the distortion,
the kinetic energy
in the distortion
consistent with each other?
These are the things
we are told to assume.
And I repeat some of them.
We assume the ring is massless.
The distortion is always
sufficiently small
so that this height is
much smaller than this.
So that this angle here
is sufficiently small
that we can approximate
the sine angle the angle
or the tangent of the
angle, which of course
is this height divided by that.
So it's h over L over T.
We are told that the mass
per unit length is mu
and that the tension is uniform.
In other words, because
this distortion is small,
we are making the assumption
that the tension in this string
is constant and the
same everywhere.
There are no losses,
no frictional losses.
And finally, all the
motion is-- because this
is so small, is in the
transverse direction.
So any piece of the string moves
in the transverse direction.
This is a reasonable
approximation to reality.
Or put it the other
way around, the reality
would be a reasonable
approximation
to this idealized
situation, which
we will try to
understand and solve.
OK, so how do we go about it?
The usual way.
We first have to
represent the problem
in terms of mathematics.
So what do we know?
The system is a continuous
infinite row of oscillators.
Each one connected
only to its neighbor.
And we know that
such a system can
be represented by
a wave equation.
The equation of motion for
this system is a wave equation.
In essence, if you remember
when we had coupled oscillators,
three oscillators,
four, et cetera.
Every time you add
one more oscillator,
you have one more
equation of motion.
So if you have an infinite
number of oscillators,
you expect to have
an infinite number
of coupled equations of motions.
That's what a wave equation is.
For every position x, you
have an equation of motion.
Why the distortion
is a function of x?
So essentially for every value
of x, you have one equation.
Since x is a continuum,
this, in essence,
is an infinite number of
coupled differential equations.
And we call this
the wave equation.
So the equation of motion
of the string is that.
What else do we know?
How can we use
the laws of nature
to describe this situation?
Well, let's consider the ring.
On the ring, there
will be forces.
One is the string is
attached, so there
will be the tension in the
string pulling on the ring.
We said that the ring cannot--
it moves only up and down,
so there must be some
constraining force on it.
If you're imagining it to
be on this frictionless rod,
then that constraining
force is the reaction
of the rod on the ring.
If you're thinking of it in
terms of a finger holding
onto that ring,
then your finger is
preventing the ring moving
backwards or forwards.
So that's this reaction force.
Now, on top of that, there
is the vertical force,
the one we are
interested in, which
must be the cause
of the distortion.
So those are the three forces.
What else do we know?
We said that we are going
to idealize this situation.
We're going to assume that
this ring has no mass.
It's only there so
you can essentially
hold the tip of the string.
Now if mass is 0, then in
Newton's laws of motion
there can be no net
force on that mass.
Because if you applied
any force to a 0 mass,
it will have an
infinite acceleration.
Your ring would disappear.
So the fact that the ring is
massless-- in other words,
you're just holding the
very tip of the string.
That's what it,
in essence, means.
It means there is no
net force on the ring.
The ring does not move
backwards and forwards.
There's no net force
in that direction.
So the reaction of
the rod on the string
must be exactly equal to
the horizontal component
of the tension.
Actually, we don't need this
for the solving of the problem.
On the other hand, in
the vertical direction
we also know that there is
no net force vertically.
And so the magnitude of the
force at any instant of time
will, of course, be
equal and opposite
to the magnitude of the
force due to the tension
in this string, the component of
that in the vertical direction.
So the F of t at
any instant of time
will be equal to minus
the vertical component
of the tension on the string.
OK, so that's everything
we know about the dynamics.
This plus the knowledge
that at the time
we were given this was the
shape of the distortion,
and it was progressing
to the right,
must be enough to
be able to predict
the motion of the ring,
the power delivered.
Now, why do I say that?
Well, let's go
back for a second.
This will tell us
what the ring is doing
and what the forces
are acting on it.
Now, if you have a force
acting on something,
and that something
is moving, the power
that you will deliver
that to that object
is the dot product
between the force
and the velocity of the object.
These we know because power
is work per unit time.
Work done by a force is force
times the distance moved.
So therefore, work times
distance moved per second
is the force times the velocity.
So this is the power
generated by a force
if it moves an object
with a velocity v of t.
From what I told
you earlier, I'm
just thinking through whether
we can solve this problem.
From the part I
discussed earlier,
we will be able to
figure out the force.
We will be able to
figure out the motion.
Therefore, we will be able
to calculate this and answer
the second part of the problem.
Let's continue.
We want to find
the energy stored
in the distortion of this ring.
How would we do
that to make sure
that we have
everything in place?
Well, if you have
some system which
you distort from equilibrium,
the potential energy
stored by conservation
of energy is
equal to the work you do
to distort that system.
In our case, the pulse
is a distorted string
from equilibrium.
So if I calculate
the work that I
will have to do to produce
that shape of the string,
that will be equal to the
potential energy stored
in the string.
So potential energy,
in other words,
is work to distort the string.
And that is simply the integral
of the force times the distance
that will move that force
to distort the string.
So that we will be
able to do since we--
as I'll show in a second.
The next part was, what is the
kinetic energy in the pulse?
Well kinetic energy
is, of course,
1/2 mass times velocity
squared of a system.
The string is-- it's a
continuous distribution
of masses.
If I take every
piece of that string
and calculate its
transverse velocity--
that's the only
velocity that it has.
We said that this string
has only transverse motion.
So if I calculate the
transverse velocity
of every piece of the string
and add up all the pieces,
I'll have the total
kinetic energy stored.
So at any instant
of time, I have
to just find out what every
piece of the string is doing,
calculate its velocity
squared multiplied
by 1/2 by the mass of that
piece, add them all up,
and that's equal
to-- therefore, we
will have to integrate across
the whole string 1/2 times
the transverse
velocity squared times
the density of
the-- the string has
certain mass per
unit length, mu.
So I have to take this and
integrate a mu dx times that.
That'll give us the
total kinetic energy.
OK.
So now, here we have the
problem in terms of mathematics.
And we'll switch over
and try to solve it.
OK.
This wave equation
has, as I told you,
is equivalent to an infinite
coupled differential equations.
It has infinite
number of solutions.
Trying like we did
for simpler system,
like system with one
degree of freedom
or two degree of freedom
is no longer practical.
I can't go through
all the possibilities
and then guess
which one applies.
So I have to use some more
knowledge or experience.
In general, as I say, there's
an infinite number of solutions.
But we know that we are looking
for a very specific kind
of solution.
We know that this
pulse we're told
was generated by this
mass-- this ring.
Sorry, not the mass.
By this ring being
moved by a finger.
Which gave rise to
a progressive wave.
Meaning a shape like this
which is moving to the right.
That immediately
gives us a clue.
We know that there are some
general classes of solutions
of this wave equation.
There are the
normal modes, which
are every piece of this string
moving with the same frequency
and phase, et cetera.
There is another one
which isn't obvious,
but which Professor Walter
Lewin discussed in class,
that is actually quite-- I
consider it the miraculous one.
It's so not obvious.
There is a solution
of this wave equation,
which consists of
any distortion.
You can take any shape.
And if somehow or other you
manage to make that distortion
move with a uniform
velocity corresponding
to this velocity in
the wave equation--
so for our string, the square
root of this number-- that
will progress forever.
It's a progressive
wave solution.
And it's for any shape.
So here, clearly we are
talking of that kind
of a solution of
this wave equation.
And as I say, from what you've
learned from Professor Walter
Lewin, we know that
the wave equation
does have that
class of solutions.
So the solution to
this problem must
be that of a progressive wave.
Specifically, a
shape like this which
moves to the right with a
velocity square root of T
over mu.
And I cannot resist emphasizing
that no part of the string is
moving here to the right.
The string is only moving
in the transverse direction.
But it is the distortion which
is moving with that velocity v
.
It's called the phase velocity.
All right.
So our knowledge
of the solutions
of wave equations and these
descriptions make sense.
And so we know the class of
solutions that describe this.
In fact, it is the progressive
wave solution of this problem.
Fantastic.
So we know what this string is
doing at all times, a earlier
times and later times.
From now on, this triangle will
just move forever like that.
That will be the distortion.
I can turn the clock around.
I know that earlier it
was here, here, et cetera.
So I know the shape of
this string at all times.
Knowing that, I can-- it's
a funny way of saying it,
predict because it
happened earlier.
But I can tell you
what the distortion
must have been at earlier times.
Going back with velocity
v until-- up to the times
when this distortion was here.
Of course, the string
was doing nothing.
But at some instant of-- so the
total picture is the following.
We start off with
the taut string.
At some instant of
time, the person
must have moved the string
with uniform velocity
up, which I call the transverse
velocity the transverse.
That'll start this wave front.
You will have come to a stop and
start moving downwards again,
formed this triangle,
and then I do no more.
This triangle will
then progress forward.
It will progress with
a phase velocity v
with this velocity,
which we know.
It's not something
I did in my head.
I can derive this
by studying how
a string can be described
by the wave equation.
But for this
instant, you can say
I took it from a
book or somewhere,
or from the lectures of
Professor Walter Lewin.
The phase velocity of
a pulse on this string
is-- of an ideal string is
the square root of the tension
divided in mass per unit length.
OK.
And I was telling you a second
ago, when I go back in time
at any instant of time
when they ring was moving,
this string has that shape.
And as I move the ring up
and generate this wave front,
every piece of the
string is moving up
with a transverse velocity
v tr, which I don't know.
But the result is that
this part of the pulse
moves to the right with
velocity [INAUDIBLE],
phase velocity of the pulse.
Don't get confused.
This piece of the
string-- and I'm
repeating myself-- is
not moving to the right.
This piece is moving up with
this transverse velocity.
This piece of the
string is moving up.
This piece isn't moving yet.
But shortly afterwards, it will.
And so the result
of the movement
of every piece of
this string up is
to produce a pulse which
is moving to the right.
OK.
So now we want to calculate what
is this transverse velocity.
Well, from this picture
it will be-- this velocity
is related to that
one by that angle.
And so the motion of the ring
is the transverse velocity
at time t of the
ring-- this part of it.
OK, we're talking
about this-- is
equal to v times
H over L over 2.
That's the tangent
of this angle.
That's the relation
between this velocity
and this transverse velocity.
Which is equal to 2v H over L.
And this is the motion of this
string from the time when this
is back here until the time
when this is moved for the ring
to be at the maximum height
H. If we remember that we were
told that the shape
of the pulse-- and I
have to refer you now back
to do original picture.
If you look at that
original picture,
we were told that at time
4L over the square root of T
over mu, that pulse was--
well, the back end of it
was 2L away from the ring
and the forward part was 3L.
That pulse is moving
with velocity v.
And therefore, we can
calculate the time
when the different
parts of that pulse
were generated by the ring.
From the time L over v until 3L
over 2v, this part of the pulse
was generated.
And so the transverse velocity
during that period of the ring
is 2v H over L.
Later on, now the
ring is at the top
and just the front edge of
the pulse has been generated.
We now suddenly-- this is
an idealized situation.
So this ring was going
up with uniform velocity.
And it suddenly
reverses direction.
Obviously, that's not
the physical situation.
That's infinite acceleration.
But we can imagine it
happens very fast that it's
almost infinite acceleration.
And so suddenly, we
change from the ring,
pulling the string upwards to
the ring pulling the string
downwards.
We are now creating the
back edge of that pulse.
The situation is symmetric
to the previous case.
The only difference is that
it's in the opposite direction.
And we know that the
magnitude of the two
are the same because
the pulse is symmetric.
In one case, we are
producing a wave front
which is at some
angle like that.
And then the other like this.
But they're symmetric.
The angles are the same, but
in the opposite direction.
So the transverse
velocity here now
is therefore minus
2v H over L. And this
happens this time interval.
By the time we've
reached time 2L over V,
the complete pulse
has left the ring.
From then on, the ring
must be stationary.
Because if it moved, it
would produce new distortions
in the string.
OK, so we have
completely described
the motion of the ring.
That was the first
part of the problem.
And I repeat quickly, you have
a string which is straight.
I'm holding the ring.
I'm waiting, waiting.
At some time when
I feel like it,
I start moving it with
uniform velocity up.
I then reverse instantaneously
and move with uniform velocity
down.
When I'm moving up, I generate
the front part of that pulse.
When I'm moving down, I
generate the back part.
Then, I stop.
I'm doing nothing.
The ring is doing nothing more.
The string is attached
to it horizontally.
But as a result of that
motion of the ring,
I've introduced a triangular
distortion on the string.
That distortion will
now propagate forever
with the phase velocity
square root T over mu.
I don't have to discuss how this
pulse is progressing forward.
That we've done in general,
or Professor Walter Lewin
has done in general.
He has shown that there
is this progressive wave
solution to the wave equation,
which describes this string.
OK, so we've finally
understood the motion
of the ring and the subsequent
motion of the pulse progressing
down the string.
End of that.
The next question was the
power delivered by the string.
Well, clearly, during the time
when the ring is stationary,
isn't doing no work on anything.
My finger doesn't have to do any
work on the ring or the string.
There's no power generating.
But during the time when
I was moving the ring up,
I had to exert a force.
So I was pulling with a force.
Therefore, I was doing work.
And the rate of doing work is
the power that I'm generating.
Similarly when I'm
going down, I will
have to do work against
the force, the tension
in the string, and I
will be exerting power
during that time.
How do we calculate that?
Well, I repeat what
I said earlier,
so I don't have to
look at the board.
The instantaneous power
generated or exerted by a force
is force dot the velocity.
OK.
Now, we did calculate the force.
Sorry, we can
calculate the force
that I have to generate
to move this ring.
I'm just redrawing
the sketch for you.
Here is the ring.
What are the forces?
I am repeating, there is
the reaction force here.
That's this force F
which I am exerting.
And I've chosen this
picture at the time
when the string is like this.
At other times, the string
will be in that direction.
But I've sketched
this at a time when
the string is in this direction.
That is the tension in it.
It exerts a force.
So those are the three forces.
And as I've discussed earlier,
this is a massless ring.
Therefore, there's no net force.
At this instant, this
force must be equal
and in the opposite direction
than the vertical component
of this tension T.
So it is equal to T
times the tangent of this angle.
So at that instant of time,
the magnitude of this force--
and it's in the up direction--
is plus T H over L over 2,
which is 2H T over L.
This corresponds
to the period when
the string is like
this at the ring.
And earlier on, I told
you that corresponds
to this time interval.
OK.
Later, I've reached the top.
I'm starting to move down.
The string now is upwards,
but the angle is the same.
And so the force
that I have to exert
is the same magnitude as this
but in the opposite direction.
Hence, the minus sign.
So it's minus T over
that, which is minus
2H T over L. The two
are, of course, equal.
So I first have to--
it actually makes
sense if you imagine a string.
If I want to distort it
up, I have to pull on that.
Later on, I want to
pull it in the opposite.
I pull it down.
Those are the two types.
So we know at every
instant of time
what is the force that I
exert and the direction of it.
Now, the power that I generate
is the force dot velocity.
So I have to take the dot
product between this force
and the corresponding velocity.
All the motion is
up and down, so I
don't have to-- I'm doing
just the components.
And so the dot product is
just the multiplication
of the force times the velocity.
And the only thing I
have to watch out for
is whether they're in
the same direction,
in the opposite direction.
Notice that when the
transverse velocity is
positive-- in other
words, upwards-- that's
the time when I'm
pulling upwards.
And so the force and the
velocity have the same sign.
So the power I
exert is this 2H T
over L times the transverse
velocity 2v H over L. OK?
Now, afterwards when we change
to the other-- the back edge,
the force reverses.
It's minus.
So that's the
transverse velocity.
And so that product,
once again, is positive.
So both on the leading edge of
that pulse and the back edge,
I do positive amount of work.
I do work on the ring
and not the ring on me.
And of course,
immediately that power
is transmitted to the string.
So for both the front edge and
the back edge of the piles,
I have to do work on the string.
It's positive.
And at every instant of
time during my motion,
this is the power.
It's the product of the force
times the transverse velocity.
So this now is true
for the complete time
period during which I
am generating the pulse.
OK.
I can now plot what
is the power that I
have to exert as a
function of time.
So here is the power and
in this direction is time.
And what we've shown
from a time of L
over v to a time 2L
over v. And by the way,
just I'm reminding you,
halfway through-- this
is when I'm moving
it in one direction.
This is in the other.
But the power is
positive in both cases.
So this is the power
as a function of time.
And so what is the
total energy that I
have to give to the string
to produce that pulse?
Well, total energy
given is the integral
of the power over the
time during which I
exert that power.
So it's the integral of P
of t dt over that interval.
Well, that's just the
area of that pulse.
So it's this height
times this time.
And if I do that, I get-- if
I take this and multiply it
by that length, I get
4H squared T over L.
All right, so we've now
understood what the ring does.
We understand how
much energy I had
to apply to it in order
to generate that pulse.
OK, finally we were asked about
something about the pulse.
I've put some energy into
it, where did that energy go?
That energy went into the
potential energy stored because
of the shape of the pulse
and the kinetic energy in it.
So the essence of the
next parts of the question
is, let's now, from first
principles-- knowing
what pulse we have, let's try to
calculate how much energy we've
stored in the pulse in the
form of potential energy.
How much energy we've
stored in the pulse
in the form of kinetic energy.
And just to check that
we didn't make a mistake,
let's see that
energy is conserved.
We know the total energy
we've put into the system.
Let's see whether that's
equal to the potential energy
plus the kinetic energy.
Of course, it's going
to work out right,
so it's more a test I
haven't made a mistake.
And we are not going to discover
non-conservation of energy
here.
OK, so now let's
try to calculate
how much potential energy
is stored in the pulse.
OK, you can do it many ways.
But normally, I like
going to first principles.
This string normally in
equilibrium is straight.
In the moving pulse,
it is distorted.
It's this shape.
In order to distort it to this
shape-- and ti doesn't matter,
I'm talking at some
instant of time.
I don't care whether anything
is moving here or not.
At some instant of time,
this has a certain amount
of potential energy.
It is the energy
stored in the system
because it is distorted from
its equilibrium straight path.
I don't care whether any
piece here is moving or not.
That's nothing to
the potential energy.
How much energy is there if I
have a piece of string shaped
like this whether it's
part of the pulse or not?
Irrelevant.
OK, how do we do it?
I will do a thought experiment,
a Gedanken experiment.
I will imagine I took a
string, nailed these points.
They don't move separated by
a distance L. In the middle,
I get hold of this and
from it being straight,
I start pulling up.
All right?
Until I reach a height H.
At that stage, I've
generated this shape.
The potential
energy in that shape
must come from the work
I did in distorting it.
How much work do I do?
Well, I have to exert
a force pulling it up.
And the integral of that force
times the total distance, that
will be the total
work I have done.
So that's what I have to do.
All right?
So what I'm doing?
I'm going to integrate from this
height being 0 to the height
being H. I mean,
integral is just
the addition of bits of
work as I pull this up.
So integral of the force,
which I call little f of y dy.
Now, what is the force?
I'm not [INAUDIBLE]
where I'm doing this.
I'm doing it, pulling it up
very slowly at uniform velocity.
So I'm not
accelerating anything.
So the net force on this must be
equal and opposite to the force
exacted on my fingers
by this string.
Well, there is a
tension in this string
pulling in these directions.
The horizontal components
of the tensions
cancel, but the
vertical ones add up.
The two vertical components
of the string on this side
and that are equal and
opposite to my force f.
Now, what we said,
the assumption
here is that this
distortion is so small
that in the process of me
pulling this and changing it,
this tension does not change.
In reality, it would
change slightly.
But if this is small
enough, it's negligible.
So I'm going to
make the assumption
that this tension does not
change as I'm moving this up.
So the force I'll be applying
will be constant, actually.
And so what that is?
Well, it's twice the tension
times the component of it,
this tangent of the angle in the
vertical direction from 0 to H
times dy.
But as I say, T will be
constant throughout this period.
But y-- there is a y here,
which is not a constant.
This goes from 0 to H.
And so if I integrate
that with respect to y, I'll get
y squared over 2 from 0 to H.
And so this integral is equal
4T H squared over L over 2.
This 2 is from the
integral of y dy.
It's y squared over 2 taken
from those limits gives me that.
OK, which is 2H
squared T over L.
This is the work I did
distorting the string.
It must be equal to
the energy stored
in the string in that process.
OK, so we've answered that part.
How about the kinetic energy?
There is a pulse which
is moving to the right.
Meaning that every piece of
this string from here to here
is actually in motion.
Over here, it's stationary.
But to the left of center,
every piece in here
it's actually moving down.
We discussed that earlier.
Every piece along
here is moving up.
The result is you
get the impression
of the pulse moving
to the right.
But the actual motion of the
mass is down here and up here.
So at any instant of time
when you have this pulse,
there is kinetic energy of
the string in this piece
and in that piece.
And we have to calculate that.
They are both positive
kinetic energy.
There is no such thing as
negative kinetic energy.
So those are moving.
And the transverse velocity
is down and here up.
Kinetic energy is 1/2 mass
times velocity squared.
They're both positive, OK?
So let's now just calculate.
Again, it will be
the integral, the sum
of the kinetic energy of
every piece along here.
So if I take a piece
of mass dm multiply it
by 1/2 times its transverse--
the motion of that mass
squared.
That's the total
velocity of that mass.
It's not moving horizontally.
We've made that assumption
in this idealized case.
So this is the kinetic energy
of a piece of the mass.
And I have to integrate that
over all the pieces of m
from here to here.
There's no kinetic
energy there and there.
OK, this is a
constant, actually.
It's only true because
this is a straight line
that this pulse consists
of two straight lines.
If it wasn't, it
would not be constant.
So this integral
is that 1/2 times
this transverse
velocity, which we
calculated earlier
the transverse.
We've calculated over here
the transverse velocity.
And you can see it's independent
of position of the string.
So back to here.
So we know that
transverse velocity.
And what is the piece of mass?
Well, that will be the
density of the string, mass
per unit length mu times
the little piece of string
of length l.
This is a trivial integral,
so they're all constants here.
By the way, this
integral-- maybe
I should've said it-- goes
over a length from 0 to L.
That's the length of the
string we're considering.
So we get up with that
equal to that, which
is equal to-- because
I could replace v. We
know v. v is the square
root of T over mu.
And so if I replace v by
v squared by T over mu,
it cancels the mu,
but we get a T here.
And so the total energy,
kinetic energy, is this.
And we are essentially whole.
Because now we've calculated
the total potential energy
stored in the pulse.
We've calculated the
total kinetic energy.
So the total energy
stored in that policy
is the sum of those two,
which is of course, 4H squared
T over L. So in other words,
as this pulse moves along, it
has a total energy of this
plus that 4H squared T over L.
And it will continue forever.
Energy is conserved,
it will go forever.
Where did it come from?
We said it came from
the motion of the ring.
And I calculated how much
energy I did initially.
It was 4H squared T over L. And
lo and behold, big surprise,
it's exactly what's
in the pulse.
So the work I do is
right at the beginning.
The work I do is at the time
when I generate the pulse.
From then on, the energy
just progresses forever.
That's the end to that problem.
We'll now deal with
the next problem.
So we now come to
the second problem
to do with progressive waves.
And the problem I've
taken is the following.
You have two coaxial cables.
They're connected at some place.
And we are told that on the
left cable-- this one here,
left cable-- there is a
voltage at every location given
by v1 cosine omega 1t
minus 2 pi over lambda 1t.
And there is some kind
of reflection to it.
They don't tell
us much about it.
On the right-hand
side, they tell
us the voltage wave
v2 cosine omega
2t minus 2 pi lambda 2 over t.
And furthermore,
they tell us that we
have to assume that these
cables are ideal and lossless.
That's one.
That the phase velocity
on the left one
is v1 and that whenever
there is a voltage on it
at any location,
there is a current,
which is v1 divided
by some constant z1.
So on the left one, the
phase velocity v1 and I1
is v1 over z1.
And on the right cable,
the phase velocity is v2
and the current
I2 is v2 over z2.
The question is, what is the
ratio of omega 2 to omega 1?
What's the ratio of
lambda 2 to lambda 1?
And what's the
ratio of v2 to v1?
Now, you may have never
seen a coaxial cable.
You may have seen
a coaxial cable,
but you've never discussed
it or learned about it.
Certainly, Professor Walter
Lewin did not cover this.
Why did I do this problem?
Precisely to show that by
learning how to solve problems
or understanding
progressive waves
on one system like
this string, we
can do transfer
the whole knowledge
we have to understanding how to
analyze, in fact, a much more
interesting situation.
A situation you'll
come across very often
in life, progressive
waves down coaxial cables.
Now, from the way the
problem is worded,
we can in fact
conclude that we should
be able to solve this problem
from our knowledge of what
happens on taut string.
We are told that
on this one, there
is a voltage, which
has this form.
If you look at
this form, this is
a function of some constants
times time minus-- I'm sorry,
this should be an x and an x.
Let me immediately correct
this, x here and x here.
So it's a function of
some constant times
t minus a constant times x.
And we know that such a function
represents a progressive wave.
If you plot this
at different times
and different locations,
what you will see
is a sinusoidal
function which is
moving to the right with some,
what we call, phase velocity.
Which in the problem,
they tell us what it is.
It's v1.
So from this form,
we immediately
realize that the
voltage on this cable
is a progressive wave,
which is going to the right.
Therefore, this
system, the cable,
must have a wave
equation for it to have
a wave as a solution-- a
progressive wave as a solution.
OK, next.
If we know omega
1, what is omega 2?
If we know omega 1,
what is lambda 1?
What is lambda 2?
And if we know v1, what is v2?
In other words, we
immediately realize
that these two-- the
angular frequencies here
or the wavelengths of
the progressive waves--
do not necessarily have
the same phase velocity.
And in fact, they tell
us that it is different.
So the propagation down these
two cables will be different.
And so these cables must
be made structurally
in a different way.
They are different
cables, but they're just
connected together.
OK.
And of course,
electrically-- that's
the other thing I should-- the
outside has to be connected.
All right, how do we proceed?
So as I started saying, from
the wording of the problem
we immediately conclude that
a coaxial cable, in fact,
is the continuum limit of
some row of oscillators.
Is that surprising?
Well, if you stop and think and
magnified the coaxial cable,
in essence what you see
is two parallel wires.
They have a capacitance
with each other.
The two conductors
have the central wire
and the sheathing around that.
Each have self-inductance.
And so schematically, it
looks something like this.
You have a row of inductances,
a row of capacitances
connected like this.
So this is a schematic
diagram of a coaxial cable.
What is this?
Nothing other than
each piece here
is like a simple
harmonic oscillator
we've solved many times.
It's simply an inductance
in the capacitance.
And they are furthermore,
identical harmonic oscillators
only connected to
their neighbors.
And so this, from
a point of view
of the response
of this system, is
identical to a taut string,
where at each point in the s
we had a harmonic oscillator
which was connected only
to its neighbors.
So the equation of
motion for this system--
well, the variable
was the voltage,
the potential difference
between the central conductors
and the outside conductor,
must satisfy a wave equation
like this where v is
the phase velocity
of the propagation
of v down the cable.
And we are told on
the left-hand side
is v1, on the
right-hand side is v2.
Furthermore, in the
problem they told us
that if there is a voltage
propagating down this cable,
there will also be a
current propagating.
And they tell us that the ratio
of the voltage to the current
is a constant.
And it's different
for the two cables.
In fact, let me sort
of digress and tell you
it is the two
quantities, the phase
velocity and this
constant z, which
is called the characteristic
impedance, which
characterizes any coaxial cable.
Or in fact, any system
consisting of two parallel
conductors.
So a wire, typical
two-conductor wire,
would be a coaxial
cable in that sense.
Since I is proportional to
the voltage, if this satisfies
the wave equation
so must the current.
OK.
Furthermore, what
do they tell us?
They tell us that if you look
at the first cable, the one
on the left, we see the
progressive wave going
to the right.
But also, there may be a
reflected wave they tell us.
On the right-hand
side, they tell
us there is only a
propagating wave to the right.
From that, I can immediately
conclude something
about the boundary
conditions of this system.
Take the right-hand side.
There's a wave going to the
right, but nothing to the left.
Therefore, there
must be no reflection
of the progressive wave at the
far end of the right cable.
How about the left cable?
Well, the pulse is coming in.
There is a junction between two
cables which are not the same.
And whenever you have
such a situation where
you have a continuous
system of oscillators coming
to another continuous
system, like two
wires of different
density for example,
or different tensions, or
something of that kind,
at the junction you are
going to get a reflection.
So where you're going to get
a reflection at that junction,
that reflected wave will
go all the way to the left,
come to the far
end of that cable.
And normally it would
be reflected there
unless one works hard to
prevent that from happening.
And here, they're
telling us nothing
is-- there's no reflection.
There isn't any further
reflection from that side.
There is just the original pulse
coming from left to the right.
OK, so now, how do we answer
the questions they do?
And so now, I will
go from what we've
learned about the
physical system
to a mathematical
description of it.
And at this stage,
you probably won't
be able to almost
tell the difference
with I'm talking about-- two
strings connected together
or I'm talking a coaxial cable.
The behavior, mathematical
behavior, will be the same.
The mathematical description
will be the same.
I should digress for a second.
If you're curious
what happens here,
I was talking about
two pulses going down,
the voltage pulse
and the current.
What happens on the string?
Well, in a string there
are also many pulses.
We normally don't talk
about all of them.
For example, if you
have a propagating pulse
of displacement on
a string, then there
will be also a pulse
going down corresponding
to the transverse velocity
of the string at every point.
So there's already two.
There's another one.
As the pulse on a
string goes along,
the left part of the
string acts a force
on the right part of the
string to generate that pulse.
And that also propagates.
So even on a simple
thing like a string,
there will be simultaneously
three progressive waves
going down the string--
the displacement,
the transverse
velocity, and the force.
Here, we are talking about two--
the current and the voltage.
All right, so I've translated
what I've discussed before.
I'll call x equals 0 the
junction between the two
cables.
On the left and on
the vertical axis
here, I'm going to either
be plotting the voltage
across the cable or the
current flowing down the cable.
I'm just too lazy to
draw two separate plots.
So what we are told,
there is the voltage,
which is given by
this expression.
That's a progressive wave, a
sinusoidal progressive wave
moving to the right.
There is a reflected one, which
is given by some amplitude,
v reflected times cosine.
And this will now
have a plus sign
because it's now
propagating to the left.
Here, the minus sign tells
you it's going to the right.
The plus sign going to the left.
Now, we know from-- for
example, our studies
of coupled oscillators, that
in a steady state situation,
every oscillator is moving with
the same frequency and phase.
So if I extend that
to the infinite case,
I know that the
frequency of this wave,
which was only one frequency.
So the progressive
wave going this way
has only one frequency, omega 1.
If it drives the oscillators
as it goes along,
it will drive them to
oscillate at the same frequency
as its frequency.
Another way to say
it, in this problem
there's only one frequency.
And so the reflected wave
will have the same frequency
as the incoming one.
Similarly, the transmitted wave
will have the same frequency.
That's why I wrote this
to be equal to that.
We can actually
formally show that that
has to be the case
by considering
what happens at the boundary.
You could never have
the two separate halves
moving with different
frequencies and the string
not be broken.
Or in this case, the
voltage being not the same
on both sides of the
string, on both sides
of the boundary of the string.
OK, so everything we
learned over there
we can write as this
sinusoidal progressive wave
to the right with amplitude
v1, the reflected wave
with amplitude v reflected.
And there will be a transmitted
wave of some magnitude v2.
And a cosine omega 2t
minus 2 pi lambda to the x.
I went ahead of
myself to explain
that this omega 1 has
to be the same as that.
In a second using
the same argument,
I'll show that this has
to be equal to that.
What else do we know
about the situation?
Well, we know that
at the boundary,
the two y's are connected.
Therefore, there will be the
same potential difference
between the central conductor
and the outside conductor
just to the left of the
boundary and to the right.
So at x equals 0 for all
times, the voltage VL
will be equal to the
potential difference
on the right-hand side.
So that's one
boundary condition.
The other one, we know
that charges are conserved.
And therefore, if you have
junction of two wires,
the total current going
into that junction
or coming away from
it must be 0 or you
would be creating charges.
So the sum of all the
currents coming in or out
from the junction for all
times and x equals 0 must be 0.
So this is now all
in mathematics.
You don't need to
know this, but this
is anything to do with
voltages, currents, et cetera.
This is the mathematical
description of the situation.
And let's try to now answer
the questions that were posed.
OK, the first
question was, what is
the ratio of omega 2 to omega 1?
And I've answered it already.
The only frequency in
this problem is omega 1.
That's what comes in.
It'll drive any oscillator
anywhere at that frequency
under the steady-state
conditions, which we have here.
So omega 2 must equal to omega
1 or that ratio is equal to 1.
First problem.
The next question
we were asked, what
is the ratio of the wavelengths?
Now, we know that for
any harmonic wave,
the product of the wavelengths
times the frequency
is the phase velocity.
You can trivially
prove it for yourself.
Just take that formula
for the progressive wave,
harmonic progressive
wave, and calculate
what the frequency is.
And if you have
difficulty, draw the wave
as a function of
position at 2 times
and see how far that
picture has moved.
And you'll find that lambda
times f is equal to v. OK.
This is true to the
left of the boundary
and on the right-hand side.
So I've rewritten this lambda
times omega over 2 pi equals
v. Therefore, if you have two
strings of different phase
velocity, for the first one
this equation looks like that.
For the second one, it's the
same but 1's replaced by 2.
From these, I immediately
divide one by the other,
that lambda 2 over lambda
1 is equal to v2 over v1.
They are no longer the same.
The frequencies are the
same, but the wavelengths
are different.
It depends on the properties
of the two cables.
So we get that the wavelength
on the left-hand side, as I say,
will be a different wavelength
to the one on the right.
And the ratio
between them will be
that of the phase
velocity on both sides.
All right, next.
The third part of
the thing was, what's
the ratio of the voltages?
In other words, what is
the ratio of v2 to v1?
v1, I'm reminding
you, is the amplitude
of the voltage wave that
comes from the left cable
to the junction, and
then continues out
with a different amplitude.
What is that amplitude?
To answer that, we make use
of the boundary conditions,
which we discussed earlier.
These boundary conditions
immediately tell us that how?
Well, the first
boundary condition
tells us that the voltage
just to the left of x equals 0
must equal to just
to the right to it.
Now on the left-hand side, you
have two waves-- one coming in,
one coming out,
the reflected one.
If you look at the equation
for VL at x equals 0,
for all times you'll find
it's v1 times cosine omega
1t plus v reflected
cosine omega 1t.
On the right-hand side, you see
that it is v2 times-- again,
with x equals 0 cosine omega 2t.
But omega 2t is
equal to omega 1.
And so at all times,
the cosines cancel
and you end up that v1 plus
v reflected has to be v2.
At all times that will
be true at x equals 0.
So you have one equation.
The other boundary condition
gives us the other one.
We know that if there
is a wave coming
in with amplitude v1, the
current that comes in,
it told us in the formulation of
the problem, is that divided by
z1, this characteristic
impedance.
Similarly, for the
reflected wave.
But we have to watch it.
There is a sign difference.
Because why?
If the wave is coming from
the left to the right,
if we call that a
positive current.
After reflection if
it goes the other way,
it will be a negative.
We'll be subtracting
from that junction.
So that's why there
is this minus.
And then, this is the one--
this is the total current coming
into the junction.
And that's got to be equal to
the total current coming out
on the other side, v2 over z2.
From this, I just multiply by
z1, so I get this equation.
And these are two trivial
algebraic equations.
If I add them, I
get 2 v1, et cetera.
From which, I get
that this is the case.
And again, I notice I forget v1.
OK.
And so we get that
the v2 over v1
is that quantity
which was given.
And we've solved the three
parts of the problem.
That's the end.
And the thing that
I would just like
you to keep in mind,
that if you come
across some kind
of a problem to do
with progressive
waves, et cetera.
If you've never
seen the system, it
doesn't mean you don't
know how to solve it.
Stop, think, see by
analogy what it corresponds
to a system which
you have understood.
The corollary is, suppose
you are having trouble
with progressive
waves on strings.
But you're an
electrical engineer
and you feel very comfortable
about waves on cables.
You can use the study of
waves on cables, reflection
of pulses, reflection
coefficients, transmission
coefficients, et cetera.
That which you've understood
in the electrical system,
you can translate
it to what happens
if you have mechanical
systems connected together.
Thank you.